so we have another situation where we
want to see whether these two figures
are congruent and the way we're going to
test that is by trying to transform this
figure by translating it rotating and
reflecting it so the first thing that
might let me translate it so if these
two things are congruent looks like
Point E and the point that I'm touching
right now those would correspond to each
other now let me try to rotate it a
little bit so let me rotate whoops I
don't want to rotate there I want to
rotate around point E since I already
have those on top of each other so just
like that and it looks like now if I
reflect it it looks like now if I
reflect it across that line I'm gonna be
oh no I'm not there they see that's this
is tricky see when I reflected this
point this point this point at this
point seemed to be in the exact same
place but Point C does not correspond
with that point right over there so
these two polygons are not congruent and
this this is why it's important to do
this to make sure that the rotations
work out so these two are not congruent
I'm not able to get them to exactly
overlap each other just through
translations rotations and reflections
so are these polygons congruent no